عبد الرحمن يستقل سيارته الأجرة
ويبحر في شوارع بيروت للعملاء ،
لكن البحث عن خبزه اليومي
يأتي فارغًا ،
إنه شهر رمضان المبارك عندما
تفطر العائلات يوميًا عند غروب الشمس ،
كل فرد من أفراد عائلته أصيب
بفيروس كورونا
والده بدر البالغ من العمر 94 عامًا  لا يزال
طريح الفراش من المرض ، فإن
تغطية نفقاتهم لم يكن أصعب من أي وقت مضى
بالنسبة للعديد من الناس
هنا ، حيث الاقتصاد في حالة سقوط حر ،
وتضخم أسعار المواد الغذائية يصل إلى 400 في
المائة
والعملة الزعيم فقدت
حوالي 80 في المائة من قيمتها مقابل
وجبة الليلة بالدولار  يكملها الطعام الذي
تبرع به آخرون
حتى حفيدتها تيا البالغة من العمر 10 سنوات
قادرة على سرد مشاكل لبنان العديدة التي
تدير مبادرة حي الجامعة الأمريكية في بيروت
التي
تركز على مساعدة المحتاجين في
منطقة لاس بيروت في العاصمة ، وهي
واحدة من أغنى مدن المدينة حتى في هذه
الأوقات.  الأشخاص الأكثر صرامة لا
يساعدون كثيرًا لأن كل شخص لديه
مشاكله الخاصة الآن ،
لذلك لا نجرؤ حتى على الذهاب والنظر
لمزيد من المعلومات لأننا سنجد المزيد
سنجد العديد من العائلات الأخرى على
بعد بضعة مبانٍ قليلة فقط ، تضع
خديجة معًا مكونات سلطة بسيطة
لتناول العشاء ، ووجبة
الإفطار ، وبقية بقايا الطعام من
سكان المبنى
الذي تقيم فيه زوجها علي.  يعمل كبواب
قبل أن ينهار الاقتصاد ، كان راتبه الشهري
البالغ
أربعمائة ألف ليتا أكثر من
مائتين وستين دولارًا
الآن أكثر بقليل من ثلاثين دولارًا أكثر بقليل
من دولار واحد في اليوم ،
لكن رمضان أصعب على
علي سوري من حلب فرّ  خلال
سنته الثالثة
، يأتي من القمامة البلاستيكية
والمعدنية
لبيعها والطعام اليوم ، وجد كيس خبز
لزوجته وابنتيه ،
إنه شهر مقدس ، لكن بالنسبة للبنان كان
صعبًا أيضًا
بن ويدمان.